there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's us again yep you guys
still aren't sick of like watching us
holy crap
it's a show you know and you never know
what's gonna happen i do the same thing
i listen to the same people all the time
i do too i mean you know
i can't but well the thing is i like so
many different shows that
i seriously have i think i have 35
videos in my watch later
and i keep adding new stuff
and every day i'm kind of like oh i
should watch that but it's an hour long
and i don't have time to watch it and
it's like you know what i mean so it's
just good like getting older and older
but you know what are you gonna do
somebody in the comments was asking if i
had seen fury of the tank movie no i saw
um
i saw the trailer i never got around to
seeing it i've heard it's good
yeah we'll get around to that one of
these days
uh zach says hey [ __ ] guess who's got
two thumbs and is going down to
louisiana on saint patty's day oh uh oh
don't get in too much trouble
yeah you know this guy okay all right
yeah you never heard that before
this guy never heard it uh zach says is
it correct to say kellogg is the [ __ ]
responsible for why most american dudes
are now circumcised that is a common
misconception yeah um
he was a big advocate of
circumcision as it related to like to
keep boys from jerking it
um but not so much uh for others but but
it is a very common i think even the
wikipedia page says it's like a common
misconception that he's the one that
there's a bunch of misconceptions about
how that became a thing
yeah it's a christian thing
and especially in the united states
i've heard a lot of people they don't
even [ __ ] know they don't really know
this but
there are some online channels that are
run by guys who are gonna kind of like
the way i'm describing
in the south
though
it's it's mostly protestant each one of
those churches that were in the south in
the bible belt were not organized
anybody could make a church we were just
making fun of the church the other day
we were driving we called the first
church of god
yeah we drove past the way to the
restaurant first church of god all right
there's never the third church of god or
the seventh church of god it's always
the first one
and it's just funny the church of god
okay that could be anything you know
anyway um
in the south
each church was like its own religion
they're cults
and some people take offense of that
just cult just means
a ch a religion that's smaller than a
denomination
maybe you should maybe like small okay i
mean i think that's why a lot of people
use the word sect
instead because it doesn't have the same
negative connotation right
well a lot of this stuff is just up to
whatever minister is running that church
there was an old-fashioned southern
interpretation of christianity that you
first had to become a jew
and then you convert it into
christianity it's a two-step process
right like a two-star test
now sometimes you'll see some of these
guys like in uh
veterans and stuff uh in the south uh
living off the grid and you know just
spread they'll start praying in the
middle of what they're saying and then
they'll go back and do a bunch of
old testament stuff and use
using hebrew saying shalom and
and it's just because that was they're
illustrating that they in their in their
traditions they're a real christian that
they were a jew that converted that they
converted to judaism and then they
converted to christianity
and that was they thought that was an
old process
and that's kind of confused people over
the years you know you
find these churches
just ruins you know from the 1800s out
in the middle of nowhere in mississippi
and there'll be a mixture of
christian stuff and then star davids and
you might find a menorah or something in
it and some people might say oh this is
a jewish temple no it was a christian
church
it's just that it's like what we're
talking about where
and that that particular that particular
type of christianity when they got
pissed off they would go old testament
on your ass they really meant it
go an old testament that was about they
were getting ready to fire brimstone
[ __ ] you know they were going to [ __ ]
you up
well surprisingly i mean people that
don't really know the history of uh dr
kellogg yeah and the battle creek
sanitarium uh it actually has a lot to
do with religion because he was uh real
into his uh seventh-day adventist uh
kind of thing which
you know uh influenced a lot of the
beliefs of the
uh that he wrote books about him that
they did at the sanitarium uh tammy says
first church of pookie yes where's
church yeah she's a she's her own church
no i thought it was funny because like
the one uh you know the the church that
we passed i was like they're always
first church of god i'm like nobody's
second or third church again it's like
we don't want to be like too arrogant i
said i would love it if somebody would
start a church and it was just called
god's favorite
[Laughter]
but uh i didn't actually uh
answer the question i got sidetracked i
guess i didn't really get it the reason
why there's a circumcision at least in
the south is because it was part of the
covenant between [ __ ]
what was it abraham and [ __ ] moses
and all that it was just to show
allegiance to the [ __ ] the god of
abraham that's what it was
now i've also heard stories that
at least on the west coast
a lot of the doctors that ran the height
that ran the hospitals the paternity
wards were
had were jewish americans so they just
kind of did it because
um in their
in their belief system it was more
sanitary that would it would yeah and i
think the chance of infection and stuff
and there may be something to that and i
think there was uh they were kind of
like instrumental in you know that kind
of the hygiene movement
uh more than the religious movement i
mean i think it started out more as a
religious thing but then the hygiene
argument took over uh to the point now
where it seems like i mean it's very
widespread
among like pretty much everybody
honestly i'm not actually sure because i
you know i don't have any kids but what
i've heard from you know friends of mine
that do have kids is that they will
basically circumcise a boy unless you
tell them not to like they do it
automatically i don't know if that's
true or not but that's just what i've
heard but it's been many years since i
talked to somebody that had uh babies so
living in korea it incredi it impressed
them korean girls
because their dudes weren't circumcised
they said you could go forever
like viagra you're not as sensitive
gramphthaler said only one kid at my
junior high was uncertain poor guy got
slammed into the gym class lockers every
day for having a turtleneck i don't
remember that well i mean well that was
junior high dude you know what i've been
january i didn't know i'm june
yeah i kind of feel like
in the united states at least as far as
i haven't looked up the stats on this
but i'm sure pretty sure it's like very
widespread and they basically will do it
unless you specifically tell them not to
um europe not so much i think it's
maybe half and half they don't really
worry about it as much
but
yeah so uh there but there is um you
know this time back to the topic it is
uh a misconception that dr john kellogg
was the one that made that more
widespread there were actually some
other doctors that you know made it more
widespread but he wasn't
i don't think he ever said that he was
an advocate of just like everybody being
circumcised like for whatever reason he
was mostly an advocate of it for
people who were chronic [ __ ]
like to get them to stop it yeah uh that
was one of his so it's a little uh a
little barbaric just a little bit but uh
a southern guy who goes old testament
and starts uh saying shalom and all that
kind of stuff you think you're dealing
with jew
uh that that channel is uh
bear independent
he goes by the name of bear and he's a
big old veteran [ __ ] big old
beard and he sells one of the best ifex
which is an individual first aid kit
i've ever [ __ ] seen it's about 100
something bucks about that big and he
sells them to
guys in sf and rangers they'll carry
them and you can buy them too it's got
everything you need one of the best
individual first aid kits i've ever seen
and he even keeps the score how many
people how many people's lives that
thing saved up to now i think less he
said was 33 lives saved that damn kit
it's got everything for
opening keeping your airways open
[ __ ] uh bandages with self self
[ __ ] clotting stuff in there it's a
good kit
and if you use it
he replenishes everything inside of it
free of charge if you give him
photographs of
the body and the the person that you
saved he'll
you know he'll uh he'll he'll replenish
the guts inside there
cheryl says uh i was raised on corn
flakes with water because we were poor
as [ __ ] i can't eat them anymore so
gross
yeah that's water i've heard about that
like yeah when you're down to like the
[ __ ] the end of the month and you're
out of money you don't have any milk
i don't i think i've maybe eaten that
once or twice i'm not a huge fan of corn
flakes either
i do like frosted flakes but only if
they just have a little bit of milk on
them because they get soggy
cheryl says also i didn't circumcise my
boys i didn't feel like it was my choice
to make for them that's kind of where i
stand on it um
seems a little weird to be like cutting
pieces off of a baby like when they
don't if they want to get circumcised
later that's totally up to them um
[ __ ] happens when you're a kid [ __ ]
yeah but it's just i don't know that
seems weird to me i'm also not really
into because i know that um i don't know
how common this is anymore but i
remember when i was growing up that
some people would have little girl
babies and would pierce their ears and
i'm just like why would you do that it's
like why don't you wait until they're
older like i didn't i got my ears
pierced when i was like 11 or 12 or
something like that because i wanted to
but i was like that seems like a weird
thing to do to a baby and it's like not
necessary all of central and south
america then baby's ears are fierce
but like i said it just seems weird
because they can't really they can't
decide that for themselves and it's not
necessary they don't need to have
pierced ears they can get them later in
brazil them girls were in [ __ ] high
heels mini skirts and carrying purses at
eight that is also creepy eight that is
also crazy it's not considered to be
unusual it was just girls clothes it's
creepy though and you know they came
fully formed like little ladies and
[ __ ] hats the pedos must love that
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
they came fully skilled with makeup and
[ __ ] you know
by the time they were 10.
like i said that's like some jonbenet
ramsay [ __ ] right there it's just the
whole it's creepy
hey
mexico may be like that for all i know i
don't know but [ __ ] uh brazil was all
like that it was just
everybody's going to move
it's not you're sexualizing it it wasn't
sexualization it was gender it was about
gender uh very clearly
defined gender roles and that's what
little girls wanted to wear and they're
like yeah yeah here you know they put
little heels on and purses they want to
be like the big girls pretend like
they're smoking and [ __ ] they weren't
smoking but they would pretend like
they're smoking remember we used to have
those candy cigars when we were kids
yeah i don't think they make those
anymore uh grandpa said i recently
watched the road to wellville yeah i saw
that too like a long time ago with
anthony hopkins in it which it's about
this guy it's like based on a book that
came out in 1993 i can't remember when
the movie came out
i remember it being okay though i kind
of feel like
i haven't seen the movie in a long time
did they just kind of make him seem like
um just sort of like a doddering old
quack
sort of you know he's walking around his
white suit and his white shoes you know
looking like a colonel sanders looking
[ __ ] with his like white
cockatoo on his shoulder and whatnot
um
the thing about dr john kellogg though
is that
he was actually not
some of his beliefs were pretty quacky
i'm not gonna say that
but he was kind of a complicated
individual honestly um he had some ideas
that were wacky as [ __ ] he had some
ideas that were kind of like
[ __ ] up and evil as [ __ ]
and he also had some ideas that were
actually pretty good and that like
people still
uh adhere to to this day he was really
ahead of his time
in terms of making various kinds of
health food meat substitutes uh things
like that like vegetarianism so he was
like way ahead of his time on that and
like talking about like the importance
of exercise and [ __ ] like that so
you know but then he had like some real
[ __ ] up stuff too like you know
shooting yogurt up your butt and you
know eugenics and stuff like that so
like i said he was a complicated
individual but he totally wasn't a quack
he was a real doctor like he did
actually go to medical school and finish
and stuff like that he wasn't just one
of those [ __ ] that
pretended like like some of the serial
killers like [ __ ] did the hh holmes
like say he was a
doctor even though he never finished
medical school was it h.h i thought he
didn't have i thought he did have well
see that's the thing though back in
those days it didn't mean much to be a
doctor yeah i was just kind of like well
how much did medical school like entail
no it was easy they're just kind of like
well here apply leeches okay
i'm just i know
it's called hyperbole for the sake of
humor but uh yeah it's just like
how much could there have been to learn
it wasn't much not really
uh so
actually in light of that so i will say
that dr kellogg did actually have some
decent ideas
um
mixed up with some kind of crazy ones
but you know like i said you we can't oh
we're not all perfect everybody's
complicated
uh yeah gramphers hammer says they made
him to be a bucktooth anti-sex quack who
poked through people's turds
um i don't know if he was well he was
kind of like i don't know if he was
obsessed with people's
bowel movements and stuff so much but he
was kind of obsessed with you know
enemas and making sure everybody was
regular and whatnot the thing about
looking at people's [ __ ] dung is not
unusual that goes back the chinese have
been doing that for thousands of years
they have a whole damn science of
looking at [ __ ] turds and
analyzing the smell
of what's in it and through that they're
trying to figure out what's happening in
your body well yeah i mean
it sounds gross but it is there is like
some legit science yeah
well i don't know if it's legit
well legit ish some things you could you
could tell we're going wrong well yeah i
mean there's a reason that sometimes you
you have to give a story
or something like that you know if
[ __ ] there's blood in it or you know
the digestion isn't happening right then
then of course you know
you could tell
it's just whether or not they were
actually uh prescribing things based
upon what they saw or what they thought
they were saying or thought they were
seeing or was it something like
palm reading
or reading the intros of a [ __ ]
slaughtered chicken you know you don't
know what what exactly they're doing you
know
maybe they're just maybe they're just
like really into scat play and they're
trying to pretend
and they're trying to pretend that yeah
again i'm joking yeah um they're just
trying to they're trying to pretend that
it's like a scientific pretty pretty
obvious that i was joking yeah uh yeah
so
uh camp guy said it's hard for some
vegetarians to get enough protein uh i
know a gal that tried it for a good
while and then she had to go back now
that is one thing that dr kellogg was
probably not right about he was right
about a lot of stuff like as far as diet
was concerned
but he was kind of more into
low protein uh diets rather than high
protein
and
you know uh and the fact that they you
know call him like anti-sex he was ab
absolutely that um again he was a
seventh-day adventist which you know
i'll explain what that is if you don't
know in a minute
but
they were very uh sex only for
procreation and he was actually even
extreme in that regard uh he didn't
think that you should have sex ever
and uh legend has it i don't know if
this is true or not but legend has it
that he and his wife who were married
for 40 years never had sex now they did
have a bunch of foster kids like they
fostered a [ __ ] ton of uh children but i
but they never had any of their own i
don't know if it's true but legend says
that he uh was abstinent uh as was his
wife for 40 years of their marriage
i have a hard time buying that but i
don't know maybe
he seemed like a true believer so
and honestly um
you know maybe people don't know this
when you talk about like kellogg's corn
flakes and [ __ ] like that but
the reason that he came up with all
those kind of foods was they wanted kind
of like bland boring foods because they
thought that that would keep people from
getting sexually aroused
eating boring
tasteless ass food
like he wouldn't put sugar in anything
and stuff like that because he thought
that if it tasted too good you'd get all
excited and then start humping
everything in sight evidently i don't
know
so like i said a little bit
it is a little bit quacky
but some of the stuff he came up with
and he did invent a lot of stuff like he
and he did not just uh food-wise but he
did a lot of uh like medical devices
like patents and things like that um
that actually were legitimately helpful
uh at the time so again
you kind of it's kind of like a mixed
bag with this dude but that's why i kind
of thought that he was so
interesting
uh zach says see this all feeds back
into this weird contradiction in u.s
society where sex is bad but violence is
good yeah that's one thing that that
that's always been very weird to me no
that's something that i've noticed as
well it's not as bad as it used to be no
that's true that's true the 70s was the
worst with that
yeah 70s in the 60s
i think 70s from what i remember i was
just thought that was so strange that
and honestly when i was in the uk they
thought it was very weird too because
they're like so you can show these
horror movies with people getting like
their heads chopped off but you can't
show tits yeah they're like that's very
strange
they thought that was very strange what
was two or three different organizations
fighting over fighting for control over
the television set that's what that
that's what
that's all it was
tammy says you used to watch a tv show
called you are what you eat the one lady
would look at someone's poo and tell
them what they were eating wrong
ridiculous
why would you choose voluntarily
to do that unless you were kind of into
it i mean
let's let's be honest
why would you want to spend your entire
professional life looking at other
people's poop i don't know they got
weird doctors that look up people's
cooches
that's true but it's just kind of like
we'll see that's what i wonder i always
kind of wonder about that and i'm not
saying that obviously we need doctors
that specialize in every part of the
human body they go where the money is
and you know specialists generally do
make more money than you know
generalists
but
when you're going to specialize
i kind of feel like why would you
necessarily like why would you want to
be a podiatrist or
you know why wouldn't you be something
like a cardiologist
is it like as gross no demand
where they'll take you or like you know
because really do you want to you know
if you make a lot of money as a doctor
but really do you want to spend your
entire professional career like sticking
your hand at people's asses i think i
wouldn't
that's true
you know but i mean when you go well
when you go to medical school and
apparently like the first few years you
learn all your general [ __ ] and then if
you decide you want to specialize so
then you kind of go and do your
specialization so there's some point
where you have to choose like what you
want to specialize in so there are some
people that voluntarily you know you
probably have to [ __ ] make certain
grades in order to get this other stuff
and another thing is they widow you
don't it's like well yeah you have to
you have to be the butt doctor sorry
yeah the medical industry is a mafia
basically
you know it's like a mafia
i know i worked for some of them
you know [ __ ]
dr mads like [ __ ] no well you know
this is a for business this is a
for-profit business you know [ __ ] no
man it's
he wasn't too happy about it actually
this is corrupt
tammy's talking about dr pimple popper i
can't believe that's an actual show on
an actual network and i know that that's
i don't understand like i i don't know i
guess i get it that people like watching
that kind of thing because there's
something like weirdly satisfying about
it but i can't watch it without wanting
to throw up so
uh zach says like watching law and order
where you can show insane violence and
gore but there's no swearing in the
dialogue and boobs are hidden by
furniture conveniently in the foreground
i know see that always seemed like very
very strange to me well like i said it's
not really like that so much anymore
um
yeah that was i kind of feel like that
was more of an 80s thing and it was
television it wasn't reality
well yeah yeah i mean but that's what
i'm talking about i'm talking about and
i just thought it was like very strange
that like on television you could show
people getting like shot or machete or
something like that but if you showed
like a boob everyone would freak out
about it which i thought was like really
illegal they just had these regulations
they had to adhere to and they did
everything they did everything they
could do to skirt around them
like there could be violence but then
you have to go back and look at the
details there